in May 2000 18 the European Commission
put forward a proposal for the Knights a
long-term the proposal is a result of
open debate with citizens beneficiaries
of EU funding members of the European
and national parliaments representatives
of EU Member States
Nizam oppositeday an exam multi guvo the
totally politic the purpose of our
building on this year physically blue
just to see investing more than ever in
research innovation and the digital
sector means investing in Europe's
future
our next programs for research
innovation and for digital projects will
allow our union to bridge the current
investment gap become a front-runner in
market creating innovation and capture
the real value of the data economy how
will we do this by working together
because together we are stronger and we
can achieve more the EU digital and
cohesion policy will keep reducing
economic and social disparities between
countries our region it will be simpler
and more flexible to be able to adapt
easily to new priorities and better
protect citizens the budget for the
youth programme erasmus+ will be doubled
when able more young people across
Europe to study this would give them
more opportunities every euro that we
invest in Erasmus is an investment in
our future
with relatively modest amounts the
Inuits will continue mobilizing public
and private investments throughout
Europe supporting economic growth and
job creation the investment plan for
Europe has proven as success when it
comes to mobilizing private investment
and creating jobs with invest tu we are
taking the successful model and
expanding it across the many EU
financing programs on offer we are
simplifying doing more with less and
placing a stronger focus on social
investments a modernized Common
Agricultural Policy that ensures safe
quality food and fairness to the farmers
who produce it
this means support for sustainability
environmental initiatives innovation in
farming and developing vibrant rural
areas a greater share of the u budget
than ever before will be devoted to
protect the environment and fight
climate change with an increase in
funding of almost 60% for the life
program the EU budget can contribute to
protecting our environment speeding up
the transition to a clean energy
efficient low carbon and climate
resilient economy and protect EU
citizens their values and way of life no
member state can meet these challenges
on its own that is why the EU steps up
its role in security and defence the
European defence fund will support
cross-border investments in areas needed
to protect our citizens
for example encrypted software and drone
technology
the youth budget proposal and magician
management's would be all those people's
to make the e use external borders
stronger to make migration policy fairer
a more realistic and to improve internal
security more funding will be available
to promote peace and stability to defend
the e u s-- interests in the world and
provide development assistance and
humanitarian aid with flexibility for a
faster response to new crises and
challenges with the United Kingdom
living the Union there will be only 27
countries contributing to the visit
while the EU citizens still want a
Europe that is prosperous and
sustainable safe and secure stronger on
the global scene the Commission proposes
a modern long-term budget aligned to its
political priorities fit to deliver and
focused on the EU added value a Europe
that takes greater responsibility for
its citizens needs resources that match
its ambition the e used long term budget
proposed by the Commission can enter
into force only when approved by all
member states in the council and with
the consent of the European Parliament
and time really matters to allow for the
new programs to start on the first of
January 2021 to give certainty to
authorities partners and beneficiaries
of EU funding to keep the momentum of
the economic recovery and show that the
EU is united and ready to deliver a
budget for a union that protects
empowers and defense
[Music]